deere les pilotes de la série remontant
son corps a été exhumé ce soir un test
génétique qu'il avait refusé de son
vivant dira s'il est bien le père de la
jeune aurore brossât le benzène un
produit chimique employés dans l'école
les matériaux composites les mots qu est
un produit dangereux pour la santé selon
une étude officielle
jean yves haberer ancien pdg du crédit
lyonnais placé en garde à vue à toulouse
dans le cadre de l'une des affaires qui
a amené à la quasi faillite la banque
publique le gouvernement a tranché un
projet de loi va interdire l'importation
la vente l'élevage de pitbull sur le
territoire français si notre enquête ou
ce soir de la concurrence pour les
japonaises un constructeur du
puy-de-dôme balancer une moto 100 %
française d'une 1000 cm dans la monsieur
bonsoir on ne peut se défaire d'un
sentiment de malaise à propos de
l'exhumation ce soir du corps d'yves
montand mort en 1992 est enterré au
cimetière du père lachaise à paris en
même temps on peut comprendre la
détermination d'aurore drossart une
jeune femme de 22 ans à prouver son
identité et puis il ya aussi large en
question la part de l'héritage qu'elle
dispute à la fille adoptive d'yves
montand catherine allégret et à valentin
le fils de la seconde épouse de
l'artiste
après un premier jugement en faveur de
ordre sari pour mettre un terme
définitif à cette affaire
la cour d'appel a ordonné et personne ne
s'y est opposé qu'un test génétique soit
opérée sur la dépouille d'yves montand
on le voit cette affaire pose un double
problème d'ordre moral et juridique
valérie gaget benoît roussel 17h30 comme
tous les soirs les grilles du cimetière
du père lachaise referme un fourgon qui
doit transporter le corps d'yves montand
arrivent peu après l'exhumation peut
commencer à huis clos sous haute
surveillance policière
catherine allégret carole amiel la fille
et la deuxième épouse d'yves montand
sont absentes représentés par leurs
avocats
mais aurore drossart celle qui prête
être la fille d'yves montand est venue
accompagnée par sa mère et son avocat
six ans après la mort du chanteur
l'exhumation décidée par la cour d'appel
de paris en novembre a provoqué un débat
moral
deux logiques se télescopent le droit à
la filiation et le droit au respect de
la volonté du défunt de son vivant
yves montand avait en effet par deux
fois demandé le report des prélèvements
sanguins ordonnée par la justice
la cour d'appel a voulu a préféré à
cette espèce de présomptions tiré du
refus de se soumettre à des prélèvements
a préféré l'établissement certains de la
filiation par des procédés scientifiques
et ceci d'autant plus que je le rappelle
dans cette affaire les héritiers ne
s'opposait pas à ces prélèvements
si aurore drossart 22 ans est bien la
fille naturelle d'yves montand
elle pourrait hériter du tiers de sa
fortune à égalité avec ses deux enfants
légitimes
catherine allégret adoptée par l'acteur
en 88 et valentin aujourd'hui âgé de 9
ans le corps d'yves montand a été
transporté à l'institut médico légal
après les prélèvements d'adr il devrait
normalement être inhumés à nouveau dans
la soirée au cimetière du père lachaise
le test génétique sur l'adn du corps
d'yves montand qu'il avait donc refusé
de son vivant devraient donc permettre à
presque 100% de déterminer s'il est bien
le père biologique d'aurore drossart
cette méthode scientifique a fait
d'énormes progrès dans toutes les
affaires de recherche de paternité mais
aussi dans les affaires criminelles la
dernière en date étant le viol et le
meurtre de la petite caroline dickinson
jean daniel flaysakier pendant longtemps
la recherche de paternité reposer sur la
comparaison des groupes sanguins un
résultat négatif innocenté le père
présumé un résultat positif ne donner
qu'une présomption n'est pas une
assurance absolue puis au début des
années 80 apparu la technique des
empreintes génétiques mise au point
barre ce chercheur britannique alec
jeffreys l'empreinte génétique est
caractéristique d'un individu et de lui
seul
à l'exception des jumeaux ouvrés pour
réaliser cette empreinte
on va au coeur des cellules d'un an
loyau récupérer le matériel génétique
qu'on appelle l'adn un peu comme on
casserait 1,9 pour aller en chercher le
jaune c'est à dire n'est présent dans
des cellules du sang de la salive des
cheveux du sperme de peau ou de l'osce
après un long et minutieux travail de
laboratoire
on va pouvoir dresser la carte génétique
cette carte qui ressemble à une sorte de
code-barres propres à chacun d'entre
nous exemple pratique dans une recherche
de paternité
à gauche la carte génétique de l'enfant
à droite celle du père présumé
ces deux cartes sont discordantes le
père présumé n'est pas le père le test
est négatif
en revanche ici et deux cartes concorde
l'affirmation de paternité peut être
fait avec une probabilité proche de 100%
et ses empreintes peuvent être faites
même sur des personnes décédées depuis
longtemps on a ainsi récemment grâce à
cette technique puis identifier le tsar
nicolas ii et sa famille exécutée en
pour cela on a utilisé du sang de leurs
descendants éloignés comme par exemple
le duc d'edimbourg aujourd'hui la
technique des empreintes génétiques
jouent un rôle très important dans les
enquêtes criminelles dans la sphère du
meurtre de caroline dickinson par
exemple elle a permis de mettre hors de
cause un suspect qui avait pourtant
avoué le crime
il a fallu des années avant que les
dangers de l'utilisation massive de
l'amiante dans les constructions ne soit
mise en lumière un autre produit le
benzène lui aussi employé dans la
confection de colle de matériaux
composites de moquette est dangereux
dans quelle mesure il est encore trop
tôt pour le dire mais dans un rapport un
chercheur de l'institut de
l'environnement et de la recherche
industrielle est formel il y a bel et
bien danger revenant françois duval
son nom est très souvent absent sur les
emballages
et pourtant il est présent presque
partout le benzène utilisées dans la
composition de certaines peintures aussi
ou en force pour fabriquer certains
revêtement pvc pour les sols et les murs
présent aussi dans certaines moquette et
park le benzène à l'origine d'une
pollution jusque là méconnu une
pollution très préoccupante à
l'intérieur des maisons et des
appartements
car dans les habitations le benzène peut
dégager des vapeurs nocives pendant
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années et
éventuellement déclencher des cancers
c'est la conclusion d'une étude menée
par l'ineris l'institut national de
l'environnement industriel et des
risques
le benzène est un cancérogène hauts
responsables principalement de leucémie
et de lymphome vers le
d'humeur du système immunitaire une
toujours cancérigènes quel que soit le
niveau d'exposition donc le problème
c'est que la probabilité du risque va
augmenter en fonction de la
concentration la toxicité du benzène est
connue depuis plusieurs années en fait
mais jusque-là seuls deux origines
avaient été repérés
tout d'abord dans les vapeurs d'essence
et aussi dans la fumée des cigarettes
avec le benzène la pollution entre dans
les foyers surtout dans les cuisines et
les chambres et de manière insidieuse
le public est souvent mal informés des
dangers que peuvent présenter des
produits compris ménagé c'est pas parce
que c'est en vente libre
ça ne présente pas de toxicité c'est
pour ça qu'une directive européenne est
en préparation
l'europe pourrait faire baisser de 5 à
10 fois le taux de concentration de
benzène dans l'air et même faire
interdire certains produits mis en vente
à l'occasion de la journée de
manifestation des médecins scolaires
dont nous parlions hier et qui s'estime
trop peu nombreux en france le ministre
de l'enseignement scolaire ségolène
royal a décidé un certain nombre de
mesures pour permettre un meilleur suivi
médical des enfants elle demande
notamment l'instauration d'un nouveau
bilan de santé à la sortie de l'école
primaire et non plus seulement à la fin
de la troisième
la formation de tous les personnels
scolaires et la collaboration avec les
médecins de ville tous les superlatifs
ont été employés à propos du scandale du
crédit lyonnais que les contribuables
français n'ont pas fini de payer et pour
la première fois l'un des hommes qui fut
au centre de la sphère l'ancien
président du crédit lyonnais jean yves
haberer a été convoqué par la police à
toulouse et placé en garde à vue
il est interrogé dans le cadre d'un des
volets du dossier la banqueroute de la
société altus filiale du crédit lyonnais
est considérée comme l'une des
principales causes la quasi faillite de
la banque publique frédéric rota
christophe l'arc l'interrogatoire dure
depuis plus de trois heures jean yves à
braire sait qu'il va devoir faire face à
forte partie car cet homme est le
premier à déclencher une offensive
judiciaire de haut niveau dans le
scandale du lyonnais le juge toulousain
lorougnon s'attaque à l'un des hauts
responsables de la banque jean yves à
braire ancien président du crédit
lyonnais et surtout aussi ancien patron
de l'une de ses filiales
altus altus sollicité par un homme
françois marland qui rêvent au début des
années 90 de devenir l'un des grands de
la distribution alimentaire
mais pour cela il faut racheter une
chaîne de détaillants disco altus va
prêter à marland 700 millions de francs
mais voilà les affaires tournent mal et
c'est la banque qui rachète le tout et
versant prime 160 millions de francs
d'indemnités à françois marland mieux
encore la banque va réinjecter un
milliard et demi supplémentaire par le
biais de mystérieux fonds hollandais
argent perdu puisque la sphère capote
dépôt de bilan
père total deux milliards de francs dans
cette affaire le directeur d'altus jean
françois hénin et françois marlin ont
déjà été mis en examen pour j'arrive à
braire ce pourrait être le début d'une
longue série de tracas judiciaires
puisque altus est impliqué dans près de
50 dossiers de ce type
aujourd'hui la machine judiciaire temps
d'accélérer le mouvement
mais voilà le scandale du lyonnais est
une monstrueuse affaire avec près de 80
procédure à la brigade financière
les enquêteurs viennent d'envoyer lettre
au procureur comme à leur ministre de
tutelle
ils déplorent un manque de moyens et se
demandent à demi-mot s'il existe une
volonté réelle d'aboutir dans ce dossier
le président du conseil constitutionnel
roland dumas ne pourra sans doute pas se
rendre à la convocation des juges vicié
ce qui est joli le 18 mars prochain à
cause d'une opération qui vient de subir
dans une clinique de bordeaux des suites
d'une complication après une
intervention à la hanche par ailleurs on
a appris que les avocats de roland dumas
avait demandé officiellement que la cour
de justice de la république soient
saisis de la sphère dumas qui rappelons
le n'existe pas encore officielle puis à
l'occasion du conseil des ministres de
ce matin jacques chirac lionel jospin et
le ministre de la justice elisabeth
guigou ont examiné ensemble et approuvé
les orientations de la réforme de la
justice qui est en cours et qui porte
principalement sur l'indépendance des
magistrats est la rapidité de règlement
des différentes affaires qui encombrent
les tribunaux en france le projet
définitif sera connu dans quelques jours
mais 48 heures après le meurtre d'un
jeune homme en plein centre commercial à
evry dans l'essonne meurtrier présumé un
complice qui a avoué lui avoir fourni
l'armé du crime ont été incarcérés à
quelques centaines de mètres à peine du
lieu du drame au lycée georges brasse
le proviseur et l'ensemble des
professeurs ont entrepris depuis
quelques temps de canaliser la violence
chez certains jeunes et de les mettre en
garde contre certains dangers à
l'extérieur de l'établissement reportage
thibault de barbeyrac philippe deslandes
le lycée georges brassens une
cohabitation réussie
ici les élèves viennent de six quartiers
différents mais dans l'établissement
aucune rivalité les élèves qui sont
scolarisés deux scolarisés en général se
sont passées les plats qui font partie
des bandes et là je je je
j'insiste toujours pour dire que lycéen
n'est pas égal à futur il un camp donc
ils font pas partie blanc pas de bande
mais des élèves qui à l'extérieur sont
régulièrement confrontés à la violence
alors ici bien sûr on surveille trois
caméras ont été placées dans des lieux
où il pourrait y avoir du rac
mais surtout on tente de responsabiliser
les élèves par le dialogue ça consiste
en quoi ces discussions passées à voir
ce qu'on peut faire pour en minimiser la
violence depuis le début de l'année on
ne dénombre que si l'incident du vol de
cartables à la bagarre entre élèves le
lycée retrouve sa fonction première
éduquer et former des citoyens
ça passe par trois phases individualisé
lors la des relations avec les élèves
socialiser les élèves en leur apprenant
parce que c'est que le respect mutuel et
ans ensuite en faire des citoyens
responsables et une réaction de
citoyenneté elle est réussie quand
l'élève
et acteur dans l'élaboration de la loi
être acteur c'est entre autres briser la
loi du silence
dernièrement des élèves ont osé le faire
en parlant d'agression sur ce terrain
vague proche du lycée depuis des
îlotiers y patrouillent régulièrement
les agressions ont cessé vers une
disparition totale des chiens d'attac
le projet de loi adopté ce matin en
conseil des ministres est clair et net
l'importation la vente l'élevage et
l'acquisition de pitbull va être
interdite en france matthieu chez clo
tic à la chasse au pitbull est ouverte
ces hommes forment la première unité de
capture de chiens dangereux en france
l'exercice du jour maîtriser un chien
dans une voiture on lâche le fixe vers
l'avant pour l'occasion les bergers
allemands de la police sont
réquisitionnés mais dans une semaine
ses façades et pitbull que se
retrouveront ces hommes pour imposer
port de l'ess des muselières savoir que
bon on va capturer les chiens y est il
ya des contraventions à donner
on va verbaliser les maîtres mots si et
s'il le faut si notre
notre intégrité physique se trouve
menacée vous savez on a toujours votre
357 avant le revolver un dernier recours
j'entre la seconde prête ce fusil
utilisé par les vétérinaires chargé de
fléchettes anesthésiantes pour nous
notre but est d'intervenir sur
réquisition sur appel de deux collègues
des personnes en difficulté ces hommes
sont aussi censés intervenir lors des
combats clandestins scepticisme d'y
aller directement je pense pas qu'on
croyait parce que les combats liés à des
personnes sont au tour donc une vedette
des combats clandestins
en voilà une guerrier prestigieux aux
cicatrices profondes
il vaut 70 mille francs il a été importé
des états unis et ses descendants font
la fortune du propriétaire
le projet de loi le pensec devrait
mettre un terme à ces élevages
clandestins
le pitbull est devenu indésirable
importations vente et l vaches seront
interdits tout pitbull devra être
stérilisés patrick paulhan ses
vétérinaires depuis 25 ans pitbull et
autres molosses sont venus grossir sa
clientèle son patient du jour un dogue
de bordeaux importé de tchéquie
autrefois il était utilisé comme tueur
d'ours
pour ce spécialiste des comportements
animaux le projet doit se trompe de
cible en s'attaquant à une race la loi
doit viser le maître responsable et pas
d'elle
des chiens bouteille d'alsace de gien on
gère pas le les excès vitesse en
supprimant les porsche enfin je veux
dire il n'ya pas un type de voiture qui
y autorise la vitesse il n'y a pas de
type de chien qui autorise la
possibilité le projet de loi vise aussi
d'autres races les staffs ou rottweiler
seront interdits aux mineurs ou à toute
personne condamnée à une peine de prison
sandrine et christophe possède plusieurs
chiens de dépenses il suggère
l'instauration d'un permis à points qui
sanctionnerait chaque infraction
quand il ya qques points de permis donc
cessera d'exister la personne n'aurait
plus le droit de reprendre ce type de
chats parce que ce serait pas montrer
apte à élever ce type de chien les états
unis on tue aussi leurs lois anti
pitbull
dix ans plus tard faute de résultats la
loi a été abrogée sur la quasi totalité
du territoire en france la campagne pour
les élections régionales s'est musclée
hier soir à marseille deux membres d'un
comité de chômeurs qui suivent toutes
les réunions de la gauche sont montés
sur scène pour bousculer le ministre de
l'intérieur jean pierre chevènement
citoyennes et citoyens
mesdames et messieurs et après un court
moment de flottement c'est un deuxième
incident qui a suivi un autre
perturbateur est montée sur la scène
alors que les ministres essayer de
reprendre son discours cette fois ci les
choses sont allées un petit peu plus
vite les deux perturbateurs ont
finalement été évacuée manu militari
après la grande réunion publique de
l'opposition à paris hier soir un
dernier rassemblement de la majorité ce
soir à toulouse en présence du premier
ministre guilaine chenu
oui à toulouse ce soir c'est le deuxième
et le dernier meeting de lionel jospin
un premier ministre qui est sur un
service minimum pour ces régionales car
il ne veut pas apparaître comme le chef
de la campagne
pourtant ce soir aux côtés de robert hue
et jean michel baylet il va prononcer un
discours plus politique avec un appel à
la mobilisation pour le nail jospin
jeux et de rééquilibrer les pouvoirs la
gauche détient aujourd'hui 2 régions sur
22 elle n'a ni le sénat ni la présidence
de la république
une façon de répondre à ceux qui disent
à droite que la gauche détient tous les
pouvoirs
enfin lionel jospin va tenter de calmer
l'euphorie qui gagne les socialistes
pour être modeste en début de campagne
la gauche parlait de cinq régions
gagnables
aujourd'hui elle en espère le double le
premier ministre va leur rappeler que
les élections se gagnent dans les urnes
et pas dans les sondages et leur dire
que si tout est possible rien n'est fait
une formule qui lui a déjà souri en juin
dernier
mais si dylan du côté de l'opposition ne
cache pas son énervement lorsque pour la
énième fois et poser la question d'un
accord éventuel avec le front national
pour conserver des présidences de région
mais cette fois ci ce ne sont pas des
adversaires qui pose le problème mais
des candidats de l'opposition à la main
de l'un déclare à l'événement du jeudi
je suis contre un accord avec le fn mais
si nous passer en passion et de ces
accords et bien nous pourrions conserver
toutes les régions et puis dans l'oise
jean françois mancel ancien secrétaire
général du rpr pose lui le problème de
manière encore plus france reportage f
vite humbert
les temps ont bien changé jusqu'à l'an
dernier jean françois mancel était
numéro deux du rpr et il déclarait le
front national un fréquenta aujourd'hui
pour sauver son fauteuil à la tête du
département de l'oise il se dit prêt à
accepter les voix de l'extrême droite et
il le dit haut et fort moi pas nous
sommes dans l'oise à la campagne mais
tout près de la banlieue parisienne
ici la sécurité et des cultes comme le
problème numéro un le fn dépasse
régulièrement les 15% et l'alliance de
toutes les droites fait un tabac qui a
passé 6 % de français qui font plus bête
qu'elle est donc comme donc voilà le
fruit le vent un électeur en vaut un
autre considération
j'en parle d'autant plus facilement que
j'ai fait en tant que secrétaire général
du rpr quelqu'un qui à guerroyer contre
le front national bon c'était un échec
la preuve c'est qu'on a perdu les
élections législatives c'est à partir de
là à en croire les concurrents ce qui
arrive aujourd'hui n'est qu'une demi
surprise
la socialiste béatrice marre avait déjà
affronté jean françois mancel aux
élections législatives il y avait deux
professions de foi celle du front
national et celle de monsieur mancelle
je sais plus laquelle et laquelle l'une
disait soyons fiers d'être français et
l'autre disait les français d'abord
d'autres parlent d'une fin de règne pour
jean françois mancel dont la gestion à
la tête du département avait été
épinglée par la cour des comptes dans
son propre canton
il est devenu l'homme à faire battre
même par les notables les riquet du duc
de noailles s'est mis en travers de sa
route qu'il est désespéré sur ce canton
il est désespéré sur ce département il
en était à la dernière heure est à la
dernière minute de ses mandats et que
tout est bon pour y arriver
jean françois mancel pense qu'il va
donner l'exemple à droite en changeant
d'attitude vis-à-vis du front national
aujourd'hui en tout cas ils
transgressent ouvertement la consigne de
son parti
philippe seguin un bon soir soit je sais
que vous en avez plus qu assez qu'on
vous pose la question mais tout de même
là c'est dans votre camp jean françois
mancel dit il faut voir avec les voix du
front national on peut pas les refuser
comme ça et alain madelin déclare dans
une interview
si nous accordions avec le front
national on perdrait pas une seule
région bien qu'ils s'en défendent
oui non mais ça objectivement le calcul
de monsieur madelin soit vrai c'est
incontestable par ailleurs s'il n'est
question que d'accepter les voix des
électeurs du front national je dis bravo
parce que moi je ne vois pas d'autre
manière de faire baisser le front
national que de convaincre ses électeurs
de voter pour nous je vois vraiment pas
d'autre façon à moins de les interdire
de vote
et encore je me fais pas que mon poids
et ce lien accord par exemple il n'y
aura pas d'accord avec le front national
je vais maintenant avec le front
national les accords
ce sont des mouvements politiques qui
vais passer puis moi en tant que
responsable d'un de ces mouvements
politiques je vous dis qu'il y aura pas
d'accord de fin de saison parce que la
caq le front national c'est une triple
impasse une impasse politique tu n'as
pas ce moral et même une impasse
électorale parce que même s'ils ont
passé un accord avec le front national
que se passerait-il finalement ils
passeraient ceci c'est qu'une partie des
électeurs du front national
n'abandonnerait aux naseaux simple fait
qu'ils viennent de la gauche en partie
et d'autre part une partie de nos
propres électeurs nous avons donnerait
alors où serait le profit alors même si
on part les choses d'amédée répit
cynique qui soit sanaa ça n'a
strictement aucun matériel en revanche
mais en revanche l'intérêt pour certains
parce que depuis que monsieur mitterrand
inventé le filon le filon il est
exploité en danse et julien créance mais
rien à faire du temps mort alors six ans
au moins d'éléments de l'héritage de
monsieur mitterrand auxquelles monsieur
je serais tout à fait fidèle c'est celui
là à chaque veille d'élection ont fait
monter le front national alors soit en
annonçant comme il l'avait fait au
moment des législatives il est pour la
proportionnelle ce que souhaite le front
national soit en organisant des petites
manifs au toit des réunions du fonds
national pour le faire passer pour un
martyr on le sait monter et
parallèlement on essaye de culpabiliser
l'opposition c'est tout bénéfice
monsieur pas de la bonne démocratie et
c'est très bon choix belle pour la
démocratie alors passons à votre
campagne vous donner beaucoup de mal
vous parcourez la france mais didier
la période n'est pas très facile pour
nous on est en pleine embellie
économique
si jospin est au plus haut dans les
sondages de prière la république il est
aussi et ça que le pression de la tuile
sur tokyo dans les sondages ça n'est pas
un élément que je considère comme
négative n'est même l'embellie
économique dont je souhaite donc je
souhaite qu'elle se prolonge d'autant
que pour l'essentiel les milices il
pouvait la chirurgie indigènes et les
gens bien fait elle est due aux effets
de la de la politique qui avait été
conduite doit tour par monsieur balladur
et juppé parce que vous n'avez pas vu
expliqué que sont les 35 heures qui ne
sont pas encore votée ils sont à
l'origine de l'embellie ni les emplois
aubry qu'on commence par nous accrocher
et principalement sur l'enjeu sur les
régions et nous essayons malgré les
socialistes de mettre le débat là où il
doit ce pas fait à savoir il ya des
régions on essaye d'expliquer j'essaye
d'expliquer ce que son évasion
collectivités jeunes peu connu des
français ce qui explique leur demande
d'intérêt spontanées pour cette élection
mais pourtant des des collectivités qui
compte s'agissant de la lutte en faveur
de l'emploi parce qu'elle s'occupe de
formation professionnelle des lycées
d'aménagement du territoire
d'infrastructures et on essaye
d'expliquer qu'à gestion socialiste et
la dot c'est pas la même chose
l'armé qu'il vaut mieux la nôtre oui
alors donne un autre argument que vous
employez c'est de dire il faut un
contre-pouvoir cela dit avant cette
élection avant l'élection de juin
dernier législatives vous aviez tous les
pouvoirs pour on a un public sénat
région parlement alors que l'iran a
lancé vous savez probablement ce qu'ont
décidé les français mais pas si c'est
pas il valait mieux à déquilibre alors
j'invite les france france est cohérent
avec eux mêmes tout simplement
d'autant que pendant quatre ans ils ne
retourneront pas aux yeux en entendant
tout cas une moto non pas aux urnes pour
une élection nationale donc il doit bien
prendre garde à ce qu'ils vont décider
tout donné aux socialistes et à leurs
alliés
c'est probablement dangereux ils
n'auront aucune possibilité de
correction pendant les quatre ans qui
viennent
alors quand une chose il ya deux
solutions du manque de scénario vous en
sortez pas trop mal c'est à vous perdez
un certain nombre de régions où ce sont
des très mal vous perdez beaucoup de
régions quelles conclusions tirez-vous
je vais probablement vous surprendre je
vous dirais que de toute façon ces
élections et cette campagne auront été
pour nous positive pourquoi parce que
nous avons reçu un message de la part
des français mais j'aurais 1997 un
message abrupte un message extrêmement
clair nous ont dit qu'il fallait que
nous modifions nos comportements ils
nous ont dit qu'il fallait que nous
renouions avec nos valeurs parce que
finalement il n'arrivait plus à faire la
différence entre la majorité et
l'opposition qui à leurs yeux faisait la
même politique
il nous en dit donc d'être fidèles à
nous mêmes et dire pour nous ces
élections ont été bien occasion de
répondre français de leur démontrer que
nous avions entendu leur message et
c'est la première étape d'un chemin d'un
chemin qui sera vraisemblablement long
il était d'autant plus opportun de
franchir de franju positivement cette
première étape
monsieur séguin journée le prix du
pétrole brut ne cesse de baisser depuis
plusieurs mois une chute qui s'accélère
avec la réapparition de l'irak sur le
marché international la crise financière
en asie et un hiver très doux
conséquence aux états unis le prix de
l'essence baisse les prix sont ceux d'il
ya une quinzaine d'années en france pour
cause de taxes publiques pas de
différence ou presque olivier galzi
philippe gas au moins un centime
un centime c'est là bien maigre
répercussions ce matin de la baisse
historique du prix du pétrole
dans une station-service à paris savez
souvent comme ça et les etam avilissant
compte en général c'est nous qui payons
les frais parce que les
les clients sont pas contentes donc on a
dû en robe noire que comme quoi ce cher
difficile d'expliquer dans ces
conditions que le baril de brut n'a
jamais été aussi bon marché
là je ne me sens pas concerné par la
baisse des cours je pense que c'est
toujours en augmentation book pour moi
il n'y a pas de baisse du trop cher
c'est surtout les taxes de 3 importance
énorme 80 % de taxes en effet plus de 5
francs par litre voici en rose ce que
cela représente à la pompe
ainsi en france c'est uniquement sur la
partie bleue celle du prix réel de
l'essence que la baisse peut se
répercuter autant dire pas grand chose
ça ne se voit pas la pompe de façon
aussi spectaculaire mais ça se bat quand
même les prix de l'essence ont baissé de
10 centimes depuis le mois de novembre
malgré une hausse des taxes que nous
payons l état de 10 centimes
aux états unis on n'a pas ce problème le
litre de super sans plomb coûte moins de
2 francs et pourtant et pourtant c'est
trop cher je fais le plein tous les
jours et ça me coûte plus de 100 francs
c'est trop cher que pensez vous d'un
pays où l'on pailleret l'essence plus de
6 francs c'est ridicule
la baisse du brut par essence et donc
toute relative
suite de la grève des pompiers des
aéroports de roissy et d'orly qui
réclament toujours un statut particulier
le trafic encore été perturbé pour la
deuxième journée consécutive donc des
négociations sont en cours
si vous voulez vous renseigner pour
demain vous pouvez le faire aux
différents numéros qui sont indiqués ici
sur votre écran que ceux sur le minitel
ou au numéro de roissy ou au numéro de
l'aéroport d'orly le président de la
république s'est entretenu avec les
représentants du haut conseil de la
population et de la famille sur la
question du vieillissement de la
population france l'allongement de la
durée de vie pose un problème d'
équilibre financier entre actifs et
retraités en france mais aussi des
problèmes de prise en charge de ces
personnes très âgées
la gériatrie a donc un bel avenir avec
des personnel spécialement formé comme
dans cet établissement détente jean
daniel flaysakier alain poirier
reportage
les médecins du service de chirurgie des
tempes christiane prat les connais bien
c'est la sixième fois qu'elle vient ici
cette fois c'est pour la vésicule et les
templeuvois c'est pourquoi vous avez sur
de l'opération sont pacifiques non j'ai
combien fondateur oui c'est déjà ça
c'est bien
retrouvant bloc opératoire tout à
l'heure opéré les personnes âgées est
une des spécialités de cet hôpital
alors ici tout est prévu pour ces
personnes un peu fragile l'infirmière
responsable du bloc opératoire vient par
exemple sans masque accueillir elle même
christiane
vous allez voir mais je reconnais mon
endroit étant que christiane ne sera pas
endormi on va l'aider à gérer sa peur
quelquefois ils ont les points de
repères ou pas toujours très facile
c'est quand même des gens d'un certain
âge le chef d'être endormi pour eux ça
représente quand même craqué une soeur
adorée fond
de ne pas se réveiller au vent une
certaine appréhension
pendant qu aux blacks on s'affaire
autour de la vésicule de christiane dans
l'unité gériatrique c'est l'heure de la
toilette
une toilette à demain c'est important
que vous insistiez le patient à je serai
très important pour qu'il retrouve toute
son autonomie aussitôt que l'opération
enfin retrouvé toutes ses forces il faut
le garder sa personnalité c'est
important et les gens vivent bien ça le
fait que vous les insultez pas trop
parce que quelquefois les calbanons sa
part n'est là on est français comme
souffrant et on aurait tendance à
abalessa dans le domaine a besoin et
pour se faire dorloter il ya même un
chariot douche pour celles qui auraient
mal à se déplacer
l'intervention est presque fini il faut
maintenant penser aux suites opératoires
propres aux personnes âgées c'est la
dénutrition
c'est un syndrome dépressif qui ne sera
pas pris en cause et pour laquelle on
n'aura pas disputé avec le psychiatre et
c'est surtout la perte la perte de
l'autonomie il faut verticaliser la
personne âgée très rapidement il verra
remettre la remettre debout et celle
aussi la faire marcher très rapidement
afin qu'on puisse retrouver l'autonomie
qu'on avait avant à étampes chirurgien
gériatre psychiatre infirmières aides
soignantes qui n'est assistante sociale
travail ton équipe pour assurer les
suites de la chirurgie christiane est
remonté dans sa chambre elle gardera en
souvenir de cicatrices minuscule et le
gros calculs qui était dans ses
véhicules
l'actualité internationale le président
américain bill clinton a rencontré
aujourd'hui le secrétaire général des
nations unies kofi annan pour
s'entretenir avec lui de vive voix de la
corde désarmement passé récemment avec
l'irak
par ailleurs le président américain va
entreprendre une tournée africaine en
ajoutant comme escale kigali capitale du
rwanda pour commémorer là-bas le
génocide qui a eu lieu en 1994
de son côté le parlement français a
décidé de mettre en place une commission
d'information sur la politique suivie
par la france au rwanda entre 1990 et
1994 l'année du génocide il s'agit
d'établir exactement les responsabilités
s'il y en a de la france dans ce
terrible drame
éric meunier insoutenable question pour
une démocratie
la france at-elle sa part de
responsabilité dans le génocide de
800000 tout 6e ronde
une certitude la france était bien là
bas entre 1990 et 94 90 son armée vole
au secours du régime rwandais menacé par
les rebelles tutsis les tutsis sont
repoussés mais les soldats français
restent sur place
le pouvoir autour entretient depuis
longtemps des relations privilégiées
avec la france en général françois
mitterrand et son fils jean christophe
ont parcouru les liens se resserrent
encore
90 94 4 années cruciales où se met
progressivement en place la machine
génocidaire pour la france est il
possible d'ignorer ce qui se préparait
non répond alain destexhe l'un des
parlementaires belges auteur d'un
remarquable rapport sur le rwanda
disponible sur internet trois mois avant
le début du génocide
la france la belgique les états unis et
les nations comme les nations unies
avaient connaissance d'un plan de
génocide d'un plan d'extermination
rwanda et que rien n'a été fait pour
prévenir ces massacres 6 avril 94
l'avion du président hutu habyarimana
est abattu aussitôt le plan entre en
action l'exécution systématique des
tutsi et des opposants hutus le génocide
est en marche
la france intervient mais c'est pour
évacuer des occidentaux l'opération
amaryllis certains militaires où tous
sont prises en charge et tutsis eux sont
abandonnés à leur triste sort
même ceux qui travaillaient alors pour
la france les français qui pouvait faire
quelque chose pour moi mois abandonnée
au rwanda ils m'ont abandonné à la mort
alors je travaillais alors que je
travaillais pour eux donc je me
considérais comme un un individu qui
était dit qu'ils avaient autant de
droits de l'homme que et malgré ça ils
m'ont laissé parce que tout simplement
j'étais tout hic il était pour le régime
d'habyarimana et je considère que c'est
la non-assistance à personne en danger
enfin l'opération turquoise une action
militaro humanitaire qui couvrent de
fait la fuite des tueurs
la france at-elle continué à aider
l'armée rwandaise at elle facilité la
livraison d'armes
alors qu'un embargo l'interdît c'est au
delà de l'horreur de l'émotion la
mission d'information mise en place
aujourd'hui ou à désigner les
responsables ou lever les suspicions
c'est à ces victimes et à chaque citoyen
français qu'elle le doit à hébron
affrontements entre palestiniens et
l'armée israélienne aujourd'hui
dans tout le territoire de cisjordanie
d'ailleurs après la mort de trois
palestiniens interceptés par erreur hier
sur un barrage il saigne à conséquence
des heures des jets de pierres en
direction des militaires israéliens
notamment donc banlieue d'hébron
bethléem et ramallah le comité français
pour la coupe du monde de football sur
la sellette plusieurs pays étrangers
estime en effet que le nombre de places
qui leur est alloué largement
insuffisant c'est le cas notamment de la
grande bretagne où le gouvernement s'est
même emparé de la faire il faut savoir
que la france pays organisateur a reçu
au total 20 millions de demandes de
billets pour deux millions qui seront
mis en circulation londres etienne
depuis un an et chambers comme des
millions de britanniques ne pense plus
qu'à ça les enfants qui rejouent
inlassablement devant la porte du garage
les rencontres de l'équipe nationale les
parents et les grands parents qui eux
ont planifié trois semaines de vacances
en france
tout est prêt donc sauf que les chambers
n'ont toujours pas de bis on n'est pas
stupides les français voudront les
tickets aux prises offre et ce sera les
idiots comme lui qui les achèteront car
on n'aura pas le choix
ça fait six mois que nos vacances on
paie donc on ira en france avec ou sans
ticket et on verra ses matches vous le
dit et voici suffit le risque de se
passer à monaco en coupe d'europe la
semaine dernière des centaines de
supporteurs britanniques se sont invités
à la rencontre sans billet d'entrée
depuis des semaines autorités du
football et membre du gouvernement
britannique
crit aux stands nous n'avons que deux
mille cinq cents places pour
l'angleterre columbia lens lens est à
trois heures de londres c'est ridicule
il faut trouver un moyen de récupérer
des tickets si les français n'en veulent
pas bref on l'a compris les anglais
voudraient un stade à leur couleur
lorsque l'angleterre joue comme les
allemands les hollandais les belges et
tous les autres mathématiquement c'est
impossible
désolé j'ai pas trop tourner à 20
millions de demandes de billets on a
deux millions et demi dans les stades
c'est à dire qu'il ya 17 millions
mathématiquement 17 millions de gens qui
sont pas content on peut pas on va pas
construire des tas de 500 mille places
que pour la coupe du monde en france
l'obtention de ces billets est devenu le
combat quotidien dans la presse
populaire britannique qui salue déjà
comme une victoire personnelle la rue
distribution aux pays étrangers de 125
mille places supplémentaires
ce geste de la fédération internationale
ne suffira évidemment pas à faire
retomber la spéculation à trois mois de
la coupe du monde
la simple promesse d'un billet pour la
finale du 12 juillet se négocie
actuellement à londres sous le manteau
autour de dix mille francs l'unité
l'industrie française de la moto qui
avait laissé le champ totalement libre
aux japonais renaît avec une bonne
chance cette fois-ci de tenir sa place
sur un marché mondial très concurrentiel
la firme voxan installé à issoire dans
le puy de dôme va commercialiser d'ici
au mois de juin une 1000 cm cube
reportage didier guyot et thierry
magnier
ans
le pari industriel et financier risqué
et pourtant elle est là la moto 100 %
française baptisée voxan sera
commercialisé à partir du mois de juin
1000 cm cube 5 version de la sportive à
la custom est derrière ce bicylindre il
y à des mois de travail et un rêve de
passionnés c'est vrai quand on pas
encore fait cette moto ce deux roues
il ya une certaine satisfaction qu'on a
du mal à exprimer car c'est un rêve
d'enfant c'est pour tout le monde c'est
une véritable moto avec une esthétique
qui sort de l'uniformité souvent
rencontré de la banalité et en plus la
moto a des capacités de participe de
moteurs de tenue de route très forte
dignes d'une véritable moto et c'est ici
à issoire que la voxan est né dans ce
bureau d'études depuis plus de deux ans
ont créé les pièces sur écran mille
pièces originales ont ainsi été dessinés
affiné corriger la voxan a été
entièrement conçue en trois dimensions
avant d'être fabriqués sur 2000 pièces
on a 1000 pièces spécifiques les miller
étant du composants standards de la
visserie de roulement des joints et
cetera
neil pièce qu'il a fallu donc définir
redessiné réintégrer dans des
assemblages pour vérification dans un
marché en pleine expansion voxan espère
produire 2000 moto la première année le
double l'an 2000 plus de 600
précommandes ont d'ores et déjà été
passées prix estimé 75 à 80 mille francs
selon la version que ce produit soit de
qualité parce qu'il est il a été conçu
par des gens passionnés ça à mon avis ça
fait pas l'ombre d'un doute de toute
façon ne peux pas je crois que la moto
justement parce qu'elle a un côté très
subjectif affectif
ça ça me fait transpirer que par une
équipe de passionnés cela fait un quart
de siècle que la france n'a pas conçu et
fabriqué de moto un moment attendu dans
le monde des deux roues
la mode du prêt-à-porter de l'hiver
98-99 ce soir le défilé givenchy conçu
par alexander mcqueen et la française
martine sitbon ce film est l ombrie sort
blade runner torpiller à la sauce disco
alexander mcqueen pour givenchy avance
un nouveau concept la science-fiction
rétro l'anglais ne donne pas dans la
dentelle le romantisme fleur bleue c'est
pas son truc
ces femmes résille et sous hyper
agressive avec leurs griffes d'acier
près talent lacéré les mâles peu délicat
nous les dans une chaussette géante de
cuir tendance sm
merci thierry mugler l'anglais ne
connaît pas la demi-mesure ans s'est
fendu sa moto
hubert de givenchy qui a laissé sa place
toute chaude il y a deux ans doit en
faire quelques cauchemars mais
heureusement third mcqueen a son fan
club
si on décortique faut enlever des
accessoires c'était un classique
revisitée d'aujourd'hui avec une touche
de demain souhaitons pour lui que les
clientes ils reconnaissent parce que
c'est sûr au dessous d'un mètre 80 c'est
encore moins facile et la création
française dans tout ça heureusement
certains font de la résistance comme
martine sitbon ici s'il ne plie pas sous
la déferlante anglo saxonne avec une
mode tout en finesse un travail
exceptionnel de coupes et des aplats de
couleurs comme sur une toile d'art
contemporain la styliste explore de
nouvelles pistes pas d'excentricité
gratuite pas non plus de mode marketing
et aseptisé mais de la douceur de la
poésie ont peu de fraîcheur en somme
sauf que pour le sourire ça sera pour la
prochaine fois
or nous quitter le rappel des titres de
ce mercredi d'abord vers les pilotes de
la sphère yves montand son corps a été
exhumé ce soir un test génétique qu'il
avait refusé son vivant dira qu'il est
bel et bien le père de la jeune aurore
brossage jean yves haberer ancien pdg du
crédit lyonnais mise en examen ce soir
après un interrogatoire par la police et
la justice à toulouse dans le cadre de
l'une des affaires qui a mené la quasi
faillite de la banque publique
la banque altus dans quelques instants
la météo sophie davant 20h50 votre série
l'instit avec gérard klein suivi à 22h40
de la vie à l'endroit présenté par
mireille dumas 7h50 demain matin dans
les quatre vérités
françoise laborde recevra monsieur
charles pasi voilà je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur notre chaîne
bonsoir à l'eau
ya une justice ce soir sur france 2